middle ground is a social experiment
that brings humans with opposing beliefs
together these discussions may contain
viewpoints that are the result of
misinformation remember to seek out
experts and to be critical of your own
biases while forming an opinion please
see the humanity in each participant and
as always we encourage empathy
there's plenty of people out there that
can separate sex and love but for me
when i have sex with someone i fall in
love with them and while i do have
friends with benefits these people are
chosen very specifically because i know
that i will have to go through
heartbreak on my own when i have sex
with them
[Music]
step forward if you agree with the
prompt
i can separate
love and sex
for me i think that i can separate it
but oftentimes it doesn't turn out that
way this is kind of the cliche but i do
think that sex for me is better when i'm
in love and when i have respect and
communication with the person i also
think it depends on how we define love
because i could maybe you know love that
person as a human but maybe not in a
romantic sense so i think there's a lot
of nuance around it i'm not really
someone who's gonna say like one or the
other i also agree with that as well
when you have those intense feelings for
a person the sex definitely like hits
different
knowing that you feel safe enough with
this person to be
emotionally vulnerable as well as
physically vulnerable with them it's a
very special bond that you share yeah i
feel like i really resonate with that
because i'm actually a survivor of
sexual assault and i'm also disabled so
i think that trust plays a really huge
role and that perhaps could even you
know be more important than the love
factor i think for me i can make the
clear distinction because i've had a lot
of meaningless sex in my lifetime to
make me feel good to occupy
the sense of loneliness and then
i've loved someone
but the sex part just hasn't worked out
but the love is there and sadly
relationships like that didn't work out
for me and i do agree with what you guys
said when i'm in love and i can trust
someone it's better especially as a
trans individual
there's a lot of people out there trying
to fetishize that don't understand your
body or respect you so having the love
part makes a lot better
i i love deeply the people that are
around me feel that love and sex to me
are completely different things they
they absolutely can exist separately i
hate the fact that even that you know
even the polyamory community is
fetishized as well you know and it's
like completely sexualized it's only
about the sex similarly to you i have a
sexual trauma i have things in my life
that affected me deeply that i'm still
dealing with to this day and the fact
that it's automatically just clumped in
is just something that i have to kind of
oppose
well i don't believe this is true for
everyone obviously there's plenty of
people out there that can separate sex
and love but for me when i have sex with
someone i fall in love with them and
while i do have friends with benefits
these people are chosen very
specifically because i know that i will
have to go through heartbreak on my own
when i have sex with them i've been with
the same person my husband our high
school sweetheart he's the only person
i've ever been with and so it would be
hard for me to separate sex and love
system because i've never had to i think
it's also important to note that some
people are maybe asexual and so if i
have
an asexual partner which i have not had
before i would have that discussion and
it wouldn't have to be integral to be
part of our connection and such my name
is jessica and i'm polyamorous to me
relationship anarchy really has to do
with destructuring our ideas of
hierarchical relationships in that
romantic and sexual relationships don't
have to be at the top i think it's
actually a lot healthier to have a
community with our friends our family
romantic partners etc
my current
relationship status
meets my needs
you know one way i know i'm in the right
relationship with my wife
we still enjoy texting each other i love
you you know you always start out in a
relationship oh i love you i love you
and then you know are you still doing
that 10 years later
we've had both my fiance and i our fair
search struggles with mental health in
very different ways but that
understanding and that support even if i
do say something really up even
if i do react maybe radically or
violently during a panic attack he keeps
coming back he keeps trying our love is
stronger after every single
disagreement in every single hurdle
so for myself i practice the type of
polyamory called solo polyamory or
sometimes a style called relationship
anarchy and these two styles are
inherently less about hierarchy and more
about autonomy for myself with my
current relationships or what i'm able
to achieve it gives me enough
flexibility for me to feel really good
about the things that i choose to take
part in and even if i'm in a
relationship that's not so great or a
relationship that isn't fulfilling to me
i can still be looking for other
relationships or maybe i have another
existing relationship that is more
fulfilling or that actually like does
support me in a way that my other
relationships don't my name is randall
and i'm polyamorous for me the process
of coming out as polyamorous was really
me deciding that getting out of
monogamous relationships because i had
feelings for somebody else was just not
working for me i noticed that other
people were practicing other styles of
relationships where they were being
truthful to their partners and admitting
the fact that they had feelings for
other people and doing it ethically
currently i am dissatisfied with my
relationship status because
i did just come out of a really bad
breakup so i am single at this point and
i can be self-sufficient enough to enjoy
my own company but it's just in certain
moments in life like for example uh i
was uh taking a long road trip and i
just like imagined my ex like you know
me caressing her leg like while um we're
on the road trip and you kind of wish
that you just like had a person just to
share those moments with
so i practice parallel polyamory which
means that my husband and i see other
people and we don't necessarily need to
meet or get along with the other people
that we're seeing and i love my husband
i've been with him for 18 years
coming up and i have some friends with
benefits but i am looking for someone
else to be like in a relationship with
that fulfills some needs that i'm not
getting from my current partner what
i've been looking for i'm starting to
probably determine that i'm not going to
find one person who is going to fill the
rest of these boxes and i may have to
separate that up into
multiple other people whether it's
relationship wise or otherwise
i'm bunny and i am polyamorous the way
that i deal with jealousy is i like to
break it down and ask myself why why am
i feeling jealous
of my husband is it because he's
spending time with someone else and i
need more time with him
um or my other partners or is it
something else and once i break it down
i can then address those issues
such as requesting more time with that
partner if i am feeling jealous
that i am not getting enough time with
them or i can take it upon myself to
fill said time
with someone else or with another
activity to be able to not focus on the
jealousy that i'm feeling
patriarchy is the root
of
monogony the little bit of like research
i guess that i've been doing and
realizing that it was absolutely
contractual it was absolutely for um
gain advantageous reasons it was never
love
way back when it was all it was like you
said it was contractual like women in
general were
an object to be purchased while that has
changed that is still rooted in the
system of monogamy and
people thinking they need to be with
someone forever and i mean i think
that's how people stay in abusive
relationships
i feel like
there is a lot of pieces of monogamy
that are rooted in that patriarchal sort
of feel however
there are a lot of people who feel like
monogamy is just the best option for
them and are connected to their person
regardless of that we're thinking about
queer relationships as well and in
people who are married to a partner of
the same gender or outside of the the
norm i don't feel like they are feeling
that patriarchy i don't know if i would
say that it's like the reason that
everyone is monogamous it does play a
role in just the way that we just
construct our realities but we see
monogamy across so many species and that
has me wondering obviously in human
society it was a big component but
there's something so much larger than
that in monogamy that reaffirms my
belief that it's not really about the
patriarchy it's about this inherent need
within us and some of us lean towards
monogamy and some of us lean towards
polyamory and that's just the way it is
obviously i'm a little bit older than
everybody here i grew up and really
didn't know much different the churches
were pretty much this is right this is
wrong you know when somebody said
plug in me i was like oh they must live
in utah that's about the only place you
knew that where that could possibly
exist and there was no discussion of why
somebody has that relationship we didn't
talk about any of that we should make a
distinction that it's not also polygamy
we are polyamorous okay so polyamorous
and polygamy are two
yeah just different things you can see a
lot of it is right just information and
yeah i know not knowing right
it's unrealistic to commit to being with
someone forever
so i feel like we spend a lot of our
lives dating and trying to figure out
who we'd like to be with and we don't
always get it right
so i feel like thinking about it that
way it's unrealistic to think about the
fact that the one person that you end up
choosing will be your forever person it
could change in the future the divorce
rate is very high in this country so i
think that's an easy way to think about
it
i also think it fits into
that fairy tale
concept that you know this is the one
and living on a planet that has harbors
like seven billion people i feel like
that's highly like unrealistic that
you're just gonna be in love with just
this one person your entire life
my name is mel and i am monogamous i've
just had the self-discovery that there's
so many things about myself that i just
need to work on and it's rooted in
me
just not wanting to go out of my comfort
zone and
polyamory is definitely something that
is out of my comfort zone if i was to
try it maybe i would actually like it
i think it really depends on the person
i mean i feel like i can only speak for
myself you know a lot of people do stay
together for say you know kids or
something like that or perhaps finances
it's you know a privilege to be able to
maybe get divorced or live on one income
so i wouldn't say that it's a you know
catch-all black-and-white issue i
definitely feel that you can be with
someone forever but you're going to
change as individuals as you grow
and it all depends on
how those changes and with uh work with
each other so if you are able to change
and accept the changes of your partner
then you can be together forever but a
lot of people change not necessarily in
a bad way but in an incompatible way
yeah i would also like to add
i did believe that i would have a
forever person but
recent experiences
of a breakup that
just happened that's what changed my
perspective
and i looked at it more logically i
should be more open to the fact that i
will meet other people down the line and
i shouldn't assume that this person is
going to be
with me my entire life i mean i'm
polyamorous but i've been married to my
first boyfriend since we were like
teenagers i think that's my forever
person
and i believe that for me and and with
the waves and with the changes you know
yeah you make that re-commitment over
and over again and i think that there
can be that forever person for anyone
but i also understand experience plays a
role in that tremendously and i haven't
had that experience of loss my opinions
of this have shifted after being in a
really toxic bad relationship where i
really wanted it to be my forever but
deep down i always knew it probably
wasn't going to be feasible and then
after that relationship i didn't want to
be in a relationship at all and this
amazing person came into my life and
i knew and i tried to push him away
but it became evident that that was just
my person
my name is luca and i'm monogamous after
being in a polyamorous relationship i
really knew monogamy was the route i
wanted to take there was some jealousy
going on in a relationship
as to how i loved each person and that i
couldn't divide it 50 50 and i didn't
want to i want to be able to give 100
of myself
to one person
oh it's kind of making a sick beat right
now
hey good humans we can all agree sex and
love are complicated but the truth is
you can explore your sexual pleasure
regardless of your relationship status
including on your own that's why we're
taking a moment to thank the sponsor of
this video lilo lilo is on a mission to
speak up about sexual pleasure break
taboos and remove stigmas through
education they are globally recognized
and established as the luxury pleasure
brand with years and years of leading
the way for personal and partner
pleasure lilo has a wide variety of toys
including the sila crews but lilo is not
just a sex toy brand it's a self-care
movement aimed at those who know that
satisfaction transcends gender sexual
orientation race and age because after
all pleasure has no gender it's all
about taking pleasure into your own
hands so that you can educate yourself
about your body and pleasure first to
enjoy sharing it with a partner so check
out the link in the description to learn
more about sexual wellness and become
part of the self-care movement that's
all about coming together
now let's get back into the video
the home environment
that i grew up in set a good example
for my future
relationships
i think for myself i grew up seeing a
lot of broken homes and people who had
divorced parents and i felt super
fortunate that that wasn't my home life
and i'm sure it shaped me in ways that
i'm not even able to comprehend they
were
a really good example of the way that i
want to treat another human
my mother
i remember her like doing it all she was
just like the pillar strength and
i think just seeing that i always
thought like okay
i can do it no matter what and if i have
a husband that can compliment that then
that's awesome my name is emerald and
i'm monogamous
my husband and i've been together for 17
years and i think that within our
monogamy there's an issue that i have
with him that we can dress and get head
on and we're able to fix that within our
relationship as opposed to introducing
other people and so i think that over
the years our foundation has been
strengthened simply because we're able
to communicate to one another
i grew up my parents were married
they've been married from my birth to
now eventually my mom stayed home uh and
my dad kept working but he still was
trying to be active in my brother and
mine's life but as i developed mental
health issues and became a difficult
child
he did not cope well with that
and he kind of like peaced out for a bit
so i don't think that set a very great
example because in my greatest time of
need i would have appreciated if he
stuck by my mom and stuck by me so even
if it is difficult for me to interact
with my child
that's not what i want for my future my
experience growing up was definitely
similar to yours my father was away a
lot so it was just me my older sister
and my mom
and the way that my parents communicate
it's like their relationship they can do
pretty much over the phone
it's that lack of communication and also
having an emotionally unavailable mother
it definitely shaped a lot of
codependency issues on my ends
my
father was an alcoholic up and through
my teenage years and when he recovered
my mother became a really bad alcoholic
i guess a good precedent for monogamy
you stayed together with the same person
till death they were together until she
died but it was not good for either of
them i don't think
that they loved each other at that at
the point in time that i saw them all it
kind of like says to me and that is like
don't stay with someone because you're
supposed to because you you signed a
piece of paper or because you have
children together you need to take care
of yourself first because you can't be a
good parent to your child you can't be a
good partner
if you aren't taking care of yourself i
grew up in a pretty religious household
there were certain ways that you needed
to behave certain ways that you needed
to act and be and i played that role
really really well you know and i was
applauded for it and i was given
opportunities because of it and to kind
of step out of that
was really hard and and mainly because
my family was just surrounded by a lot
of secrecy we don't talk about things
we shift them under the rug and we just
bury our emotions as much as we can so
that we don't really have to deal with
it and that is not at all how i'm
choosing to lead my life my name is
katie and i'm polyamorous i struggled
with my faith and also being a
polyamorous person because this is
absolutely completely frowned upon in
our community i was a worship pastor for
many many years in a very conservative
church when i started to just be a
little bit more truthful with who i was
i had to really re-wrap my mind around
what i truly conceived god to be
and what that love towards me looks like
i realized there was just no way that i
could keep hiding this really important
part of myself
a polyamorous relationship is
appropriate for raising a family
so i have a six-year-old and me and my
two partners we raise him and
baltimore city you know schools knows
about it my son has an iep so that means
he has some learning disabilities and
there's three people to support to be
there for him so i don't know i think
for me just it's allowed me the freedom
to
you know kind of go after goals go after
dreams and have the support system still
at home and i know my son is lacking
nothing
i mean it's it's tricky because
you know you have other little kids are
like oh why does lucas have two moms and
a dad you know and it's just kind of
easy to just be you know families just
look different sometimes
just being more open about it even that
in itself is going to give kind of just
more space for these families structures
to be just respected because i know that
in my community i think we're the only
ones really kind of openly being this
way about who we are
and we haven't seen any sort of backlash
or anything like that so you know like
logically practically it does make sense
to have that support and we're also
talking about kids when we say family i
think it expands much further than that
and so you see people who already have
multiple parents with step dads stepmoms
and so i see no reason that this is not
an addition to that you know so i just
want to put that forth too
you know the one thing i heard is the
three of you
whatever you got to do
you're going to do so he can
be successful and loved and cared for
and feel safe and be safe
my name is mike and i am monogamous what
i love about my wife so much and makes
our marriage special is asia puts up
with me and we have found ways that we
support each other
with what we like to do professionally
and spiritually and help out and i think
that's a lot of what i took away today i
saw that with the other side so as for
like my household we have five children
our parents live two and a half hours
away so it's mainly us doing the brunt
of the school pickups drop off all that
kind of stuff
while i do see that it will be very
beneficial to have someone else i think
that's why nannies are available
babysitters that kind of thing trying to
add someone else to our lifestyle would
make me so anxious it would just be like
oh my gosh there's another person in the
house that needs something that has to
do something and then somebody else have
to deal with and then they possibly want
sex tonight i would be like
i'm over it so that's it
that's how it works
medical calendars exist like i get what
you're saying and that there is like a
lot of that in the polymerase community
where you're interested in someone and
they're like hey look i really like you
but i just don't have the bandwidth
right now to add another partner but at
the same note if you or your husband got
another partner they could watch the
kids while the two of you go out on a
date night like that would
add time for you and your your husband
to be able to go off while like because
they could you know be integrated into
the family
all right we can cut
[Music]
[Applause]
you